los 27 países de la unión europea
sancionan de nueva o venezuela las
medidas restrictivas de este lunes se
aplican sobre 19 funcionarios y altos
cargos del gobierno de nicolás maduro
cifra que eleva 55 de las personas
sancionadas en un comunicado de los
ministros de asuntos exteriores europeos
dijeron los individuos añadidos a la
lista son responsables en particular de
menoscabar los derechos electorales de
la oposición y el funcionamiento
democrático de la asamblea nacional y
por serias violaciones de los derechos
humanos y restricciones de libertades
fundamentales
las nuevas sanciones implican la
prohibición de entrar al territorio
comunitario y la congelación de los
activos y bienes que tengan en la unión
europea'
en una intervención virtual durante la
inauguración de las sesiones del consejo
de derechos humanos de la onu el
mandatario venezolano respondió así como
también ratificó que no aceptaremos la
injerencia o intervención de ningún
mecanismo inquisidor contra nuestra
patria venezuela que pretenda usar la
justa causa de los derechos humanos
herramienta política para un cambio de
gobierno un cambio de régimen por la
fuerza en nuestro país maduro dijo
además que la congelación de sus activos
representa una amenaza para la lucha
contra la pandemia de kobe 19 venezuela
ha sido privada de al menos 30 mil
millones de dólares en efectivo que
forma parte de los activos de la
republica en el exterior recursos que
debieron y deben ser utilizados para
atender la salud la alimentación y los
derechos integrales de nuestro pueblo
las sanciones llegan después de que el
bloque europeo expresara que las
elecciones parlamentarias del pasado 6
de diciembre en venezuela- ganadas por
el chavismo no cumplieron los estándares
democráticos los 27 no reconocen al
actual parlamento y se han mostrado
partidarios de trabajar con el líder de
la oposición juan guaidó para poder
celebrar nuevos comicios en el país es
respaldar los mecanismos de solución al
conflicto